shake it
Scott Butterworth Duke Nukem 3d is back
it's got a new name it's called Duke
Nukem 3d 20th anniversary world young
nicely done
yeah hail to the ten points to
Gryffindor baby that's definitely a Duke
reference yeah we got to play it a bunch
we went into a hotel room not in a
creepy way gah - with all of our limbs
and organs clothing but I got to play
for like thirty minutes you got to play
for 45 minutes just yeah we were just
kind of sitting there chatting with the
developers about what they've kind of
done with the game and got to even play
one of the the new levels there are
eight new levels which we can't talk
about yet which I was yeah I wasn't
getting a segue into that but yeah there
there are eight new levels from a couple
of the original designers which is
really cool actually got some of the
band back together John st. John
re-recorded all of his lines that the
voice of Duke the original composer Lee
Jackson came back and it's music a
couple of the key designers are back to
do new level stuff from what I
understand all of the new levels are
kind of just remix in old assets they've
added very little because they wanted it
to feel like oh this could have come out
in you know 1996-97 I'm one of the
things that they've added what you just
saw in that game play a second ago was
the ability to well they've redone it an
entirely new engine so I know I mean it
kind of doesn't look like it because
they've tried to stay as true to the
original Duke as possible but this is a
you know it's got 3d buildings in it in
3d environments and the original was
using all manner of weird magic Rita
yeah it look like there was 3d and when
you look up at the buildings and it does
this like crazy perspective thing it
looks like you've got like vertigo yeah
when you switch into the new version it
doesn't do that they seem to have struck
a pretty good balance between like true
- for like the way you're sort of
nostalgia room remembers it as opposed
to how it actually looked but if you
want you can just swap back straightaway
by hitting down on the d-pad I think -
yeah and it's on the fly like it'll
switch back and forth seamlessly that's
kind of cool I think I do it here
actually in a second about yeah that's
what I used to look like and this is
great for the podcast listeners yeah
look at hot billiards action yeah and
it's basically do like it's straight off
yeah has the the same it's it's one for
one one of the weird things in this
level we went into a bar and there was I
did not notice this when I was a kid but
there is a television with a wife
Branko yeah it's a [ __ ] oh gee
reference I notice that when I was
watching that's weird yeah yeah and they
were like oh yeah that's totally told
you friends and they weren't they
weren't like subtle about it all I kept
that's what it was so they kept all that
stuff in and so one of the additions to
this though is developer or commentary
oh that way I was just pretty cool the
way they've done it actually like
they've just dotted icons around the
environments and you just walk up these
little speaker icons and hit play and
that you'll just have somebody talking
in your ear about that specific part of
the world it's kind of interesting the
way they've done it and get this insight
yeah fans of portal and half-life will
remember those because that was the same
way that Valve put them into those games
but I will say that from what we listen
to
they sound like a lot more off-the-cuff
which I kind of like yeah it's basically
just like Randy Pitchford and a bunch of
like the developers just like riff Enosh
he has Alan Blum and uh who's the other
love Laura whose last name I can't
remember right level Lord yeah he's
changed officially legally changed his
name
Richard level towards mr. level Lord to
you it's great the stuff we were
listening to it was very unvarnished
like oh yeah it was just super
off-the-cuff like if there's one point
where Randy pitcher was like oh watch
this as if we're actually watching him
play and it's like that's not really how
this works so it's great that it's just
so off-the-cuff it was it was pretty fun
to just listen to a weird riff track so
it's got the replay mechanic which I
think was in the 360 version console
version of which megaton right edition
Nosa Megaton was the sort of like
supposedly definitive edition that was
available on good old games up until
about a year ago and then there was some
lawsuit shenanigans yes so yes so the
rewind mechanic was introduced in the
360 version they've now kind of improved
it so for people who aren't familiar
duke3d way back in the day if you died
you started over because it was that
kind of game so at one point you started
over in the level level yeah correct
so during one of the many many reissues
of this game a rewind mechanic was added
so if you died you could actually back
up your play session by a few seconds
and go like he could not die and not
have to restart so they've actually not
only included that but improved it but I
think they have left out some of the
content that was available in Megaton
like basically just the four of the
original chapters and then this new one
which is embargoed at the moment but
we'll be able to guess it be clear it's
like it's duke3d the first four chapters
and eight new levels that's what's in
this edition and the replay mechanic you
can go back to the start at level as
well yeah you come back yeah it's
actually a pretty lenient and what
you'll let it allows you to do and
that's pretty much it like it's it's
there's not really much else to say
about this if you're a fan of Duke Nukem
3d I think this is an interesting to go
back to I think they're pricing at 20
bucks I believe is 20 bucks and it's out
in October it's out early October so you
don't have to wait long to try it out
for yourself and know that later this
month we'll have some more information
about the new levels which we can't
share yet but it'll be available on
gamespot.com is it weird I feel like now
is the right time for do like a Duke
like that you know like why cuz it is
weird right because it's it's also a
game where you're like you're in like a
movie theater where it is like weird
it's like a porn theater a girl
masturbating on stage like I was
watching the video her hand is going up
and down like they're not hiding
anything you walk up to a random woman
give her money and say shake it baby
she's not even on stage she's just
hanging it yeah yeah that's the weird
one just like the girl standing in the
corner of a bar cause he's like just
it's yeah like she takes the money so I
believe I play this game when I was
probably like ten just know like
probably it was my dad who showed it to
me and looking back now I was like oh he
was weird like I think I saw it
Terminator 2 and I was like 7 like yeah
let me just have all the media I wanted
I remember watching the Robocop with my
dad when I was like way too young when a
Robocop yeah yeah I don't know how my
mom let this one slip by well I mean old
Renee might have been one of those like
one of the series that like sure there
have been some efforts to like make it
relevant again but none of them really
struck a nerve and I yeah like just you
know what let's just let's redo the one
like you were saying like and make it
look the way that we probably remember
it yeah which is an interesting Marie of
it yeah no I was actually wrong Gilbert
the designer of maniac mansion
I was I was talking about his new game
symbol we'd park a few months ago GDC
and it was this whole idea of well we
want this game to feel like how you
remember this games feeling because you
don't remember them as accurately as you
think you do so
this is kind of the same thing where
it's like if you were to go back and
play the unlike unpolished original
version you'd be like oh my god this is
practically unplayable so this is now a
kind of definitive version that should
look and feel how you remember anything
and if you don't then you can just sit
down and remember and go oh go back to
it you need to play it on a big honkin
CRT round I know you still have at least
a couple of odd right Peter
playing that's it Duke Nukem 3d 20th
anniversary world tour a lot of words do
you know they're really stay for that
one I don't remember the exact day I
know that it's early October probably
around the same time as gears cool for
that DN 3d - aw t ok D in 3d - aw T yeah
well go with that I mean that sounded
accurate no idea what was it - - aw D no
WT - eh
we didn't bring it to the bottom of this
fan it's important work leave it to us
I'm gonna change the 3 to a T as well so
it's dense [ __ ] sounds like a you use
twice that's inappropriate sounding
dance twice you might want to dance
twice nope oh yeah that word means
something it does